well today is the day to put caramel on
everything even your popcorn yeah to
celebrate a few sweet national days
rocky hung out with the popcorn girl
herself
happy national caramel day and tomorrow
happy national caramel popcorn day so i
figured
we come to a place that you can
celebrate both and that is popcorn girl
here
in vegas you are born and raised here
yeah and you are the popcorn queen
so let's start popping what's going on
here how does it work well first we're
our first step in making caramel popcorn
obviously is the pop
popcorn it doesn't just come all out
with caramel right
so here we go out of it you'll see it
it's starting to it's starting to
start to uh come out here whoa
so you're used to making popcorn in your
microwave this is the real deal yeah
so once it pops once it pours out here
then you mix it up here
oh my gosh right here it comes
i love it okay so this is step one step
one what is step two okay so step two is
we pour the finished popcorn right in
here
and it's cooked it now for five minutes
and now it's gonna come out at that
oh my gosh have you ever seen fresh
caramel popcorn
right out of the what do you call that
thing i don't want to call it a pie it's
a caramelizer it's a
caramelizer ooh and how long does that
take how long does the process
how long does that take from the time
you put to start the cooking of the
caramel the whole process is an
hour an hour you guys this is a serious
operation here they're putting in some
thyme and some work
into your caramel popcorn so so now he's
got to separate it or it'll stick
together
okay so you get those this very popcorn
was that i don't like yeah right you
want each little
each little kernel yeah yeah okay i love
it okay so let's talk about the caramel
itself because that's
what today is all about and what
tomorrow is all about what goes into the
perfect caramel recipe
well i know we have the ingredients over
here yes it's gonna be
butter brown sugar some sugar and some
vanilla
okay okay uh this is you know
just you can't fail yeah yeah i know you
can't fill with brown sugar and butter
right vanilla right who does this
because this is unique to popcorn girl
because sometimes you just use the
something to use just powdery caramel
yes this is what separates you guys
that's right in fact when you buy these
cookers they come with
you know powdered caramel and you just
throw it right away ah
this that's not right i'm gonna use the
real premium stuff here okay coming up
later
we're going to talk about the other
flavors that popcorn girl has to offer
because it is a long
unique menu which i love all right so
stay tuned for that